you should probably just have a little
sip of a little something and go to work
drunk
[Music]
I'm Sona and I fix lives and so far I've
fixed a lot of lives and I'm gonna fix
more by giving really bad advice that's
not very good I give really bad advice
that usually doesn't help people at all
I would not listen to this advice if I
were you
disclaimer again I am not qualified I
don't know what I'm talking about
I have no qualifications I'm not good
but I have fun so take this advice with
a grain of salt because it's probably
not good also I talk about myself a lot
alright let's go thunk thunk asks I'm
shy how do I overcome it you become an
extrovert just I don't know change the
wiring in your brain I honestly have no
idea cuz I've not shy I've never been
shy so I don't know how you go from
being shy to not shy but maybe like I
don't know maybe lean into it become
like that mysterious person just like
wear a lot of black and just kind of
like make yourself if you're shy and you
don't want to talk to anybody
make it cool like wear some eyeliner
even if you're a guy like just worse
like make your eyes really dark and just
kind of like brood off in the corner
like that just do that
that's all check how do I teach my
teenage boys to have better hygiene when
I think of teenage boys I just think of
a masturbating all the time I don't have
any teenage boys but that's what I
picture in my head is they're probably
just masturbating all the time so
whatever you smell from them it's
probably semen look they're gonna be
gross most guys are gross and they're
never gonna grow out of it until they
meet somebody who's not gross who helps
them not be disgusting uh I can't even
tell you how many guys I've met where if
they friends or guys I dated we're when
I've gone to their house I've seen a
dish and it's like the stuff that was on
there is crusty and these are like
grown-ass men in their 20s I don't know
why people are like this and you know
what a lot of women are like this too
but some people are just gonna be gross
so how do you teach your teenage boys
you know what you don't they're not
gonna get any better I'm sorry I have to
move on I hope that helped Jared
Fairclough asked I'm starting a new job
today how can I get over the new job
nerves drink you should probably just
have a little sip of a little something
and go to work drunk be a little buzzed
that helps me a lot when I'm nervous
Guinea can you hear Conan singing you
think okay anyway good luck on that new
job and I'm sure you're gonna be great
just keep reminding yourself that you're
gonna do a good job they hired you for a
reason
and just remember that and try not to be
nervous but if you are it's okay they're
expecting you to be nervous every time
interns start or a new person starts
here I expect I'm gonna be nervous
Linds Brenner Jimena Cimino said I'm
pregnant enough to be sober around my
in-laws this year help with four
exclamation points oh my god um you're
pregnant which means that you're tired a
lot and that you have weird cravings
because now there's baby growing inside
you you have all kinds of excuses to
just skip out on things that is
literally the only reason I'm trying to
get pregnant right now and that was
really personal she's pretty mean I
don't mind telling you guys I'm married
and my husband and I would have a baby
there you go uh so Linds you know what
just use use the baby growing inside to
you to make all kinds of excuses just go
to your room you need to lay down you
need to binge Netflix it's important the
baby wants it so you're welcome happy
holidays Brie Garcia 2003 says should I
taxidermy my dog no Rob and the giant
sour patch asks should I buy it to pay
no don't buy to pay Eddie
Enders says how do I get abs
I don't know here's why I don't have abs
I've never had abs I'm not an AB person
I am this is my problem area like all of
this is my problem area and so when I
gain weight this just becomes bigger and
oh my god someone something and I hope
she doesn't follow these Instagram
stories she asked me she didn't say are
you pregnant
she said when is the baby due like she
was so confident that I was pregnant
this asked me when the baby was due and
I was wearing like a like kind of like a
tighter outfit and I've always had a
pooch and that's fine but come on why
would you ask someone if you're not
completely they're not like out here
don't say that but I'm over it it
doesn't bother me anyway I wish I could
tell you how to get abs I you know what
once I lost a lot of weight and the
secret was diet and exercise like who
would have thought honestly diet and
exercise so maybe try that maybe try
some crunches I have no idea when you
find out why don't you let me know and
you're welcome journey of Josh asks how
do I manage my curly hair I've come to
the right place uh here's my process I
wash it like maybe once a week as in my
hair not my body and watch that every
day I flip my hair over and I put in an
oil some sort of oil then I put in
leave-in conditioner then I do mousse I
do most like it's 1985 and that's why my
hair is crunchy alive and then I put in
a curl cream then I twist sections of it
into curls to make sure the curls are
good and then I get a towel and I smash
it and then then I put it up in a bun so
all of that is complete
time enjoy your great curly hair and
you're welcome how to ask out my crush
uh I don't know why I'm laughing
that's a really serious question how to
ask out my crush ah how did I used to
ask out my crushes you know what oh my
god I have a story it's gonna be really
quick and this might not even help you
out so one of my first boyfriends I met
at the commissary in at Burbank and NBC
and I met him and I didn't know anything
about him I didn't even know his name
but I knew he was gonna be on a TV show
that night so I after I after I met him
I went and I talked to my friend who
worked on that TV show and I got his
name and I stalked him on Facebook and
he wasn't on Facebook and this is back
when myspace existed and I stalked him
on MySpace and I found him but I didn't
have a myspace account so I logged in
with my friend's account and then I sent
him a message and I said hey you
probably won't remember me but I was the
girl you met at the commissary at NBC in
Burbank and he was like oh I remember
you and then I just asked him out and
then we dated for two and a half years
anyway so how to ask out your crush find
their myspace account
and and do you know honestly now with
like texting and stuff just text isn't
that easy to just text someone out if
they say no it's their loss
that's it